[Musique]
ce jeudi 19 juillet le président du
département cyrille melchior s'est rendu
sur le chantier de la nouvelle liaison
de la route départementale 2 et de la
route départementale quatre dans les
hauts de saint-paul dans les véhicules
empruntent quotidiennement les deux
routes départementales en direction de
la route nationale une
un nouveau tracé fortement attendue par
les usagers en fait cette route était un
rack ou aussi comme vous avez dit elle
aura aussi devenu une route de
circulation normale or le petit tronçon
de route qui passa sans souci pour aller
vers camby tu ne peux pas supporter 9000
véhicules jour
moi je me mets à la place des habitants
qui habite juste à côté de ce tronçon de
route tous les jours voir 9000 véhicules
passés à côté de la case dans des
conditions de sécurité très minimaliste
ça devrait dangereux c'est pour cela que
je me suis battu et nous arrivons donc
au bout de nos peines avant la fin de
l'année comme je les dis eh bien les
habitants de sans souci pour endormi un
peu plus tranquillement les voitures
passeront un peu moins de leur case
passeront ici sur ce pont sur la ravine
la plaine un ouvrage d'art d'une portée
de 101 mètres pour un montant s'élevant
à plus de 20 millions d'euros
un chantier qui devrait voir le jour
avant la fin de l'année après un retard
de trois ans nous avons rencontré comme
vous pouvez le constater les difficultés
première difficulté donc défaillance
d'une entreprise qui avait en charge la
construction de la charpente métallique
vous voyez derrière moi nous on a dû
résilier repartir sur une nouvelle
organisation avec les entreprises
restantes redémarrage et euros de
nouveaux problèmes avec une entreprise
le nouveau résiliation nouvelle
organisation est donc depuis août 2010
est maintenant on avance très
convenablement et nous espérons livrés
au plus vite cet ouvrage au plus tard le
20 décembre de cette année 2018 après la
pose de la première bordure du dernier
tronçon routier qui concerne la
réalisation d'un carrefour giratoire sur
la route départementale 4 une visite
chantier finalisé de création de
trottoirs entre la route départementale
5 et le chemin de la giroday a été
effectué le département a financé ces
travaux hauteur de 220 mille euros pour
sécuriser la circulation piétonne et
améliorer l'évacuation des eaux
pluviales
[Musique]